So, how are you enjoying your Christmas holiday boys? Well,
that's when we're recording this breakfast,
we are recording this during the Christmas holiday, 20,
20 we've we've had our Christmas yeah. Episodes,
but we are enjoying our Christmas holidays right now,
even though we're still technically working.
I think I took two days off and then I was like, right.
A whole two days back to it, then back to YouTube. I don't know.
I really, I even like going one day without YouTube. I'm like,
I want to do something. Like, I want to make something I want to entertain.
I want to be a clown. I don't know why you're a clown every day. It's all right.
It's pretty, some deep insecurity that happened during my childhood.
It makes me strive to want to entertain. I don't know why, but yeah,
I don't know. It was nice. It was fun. I it's nice having,
I think the difference between like a holiday that is everyone's holiday
and one that you set for yourself is that when it's like, uh,
like a national holiday, you're like, well, I have to, I guess like obligated.
Yeah. Yeah. But then sometimes, you know, you're, you're not your head space is,
and then it's, you're like, man, I kind of want to take a vacation, but like,
I don't want to, but then when, if you do it yourself,
you hype yourself up for it. You're like I'm taking this time off. No,
one's going to tell me what to do. But on Christmas you're like,
I kind of want to, like, I don't like make a video. I'm like, around.
It was by the Christmas holidays. I've well,
I've always ended up working during the Christmas holidays because I've had my
yearly videos that probably won't happen this year, but that's probably,
that's mostly what I'm working on during the Christmas holidays. Um,
and then I realized that, you know, as YouTube as you used to take a break,
right. And it feels, I don't know what it is, but do you ever get,
you know, sometimes we take breaks during the weekdays, right? To us.
We don't like weekends don't technically exist,
but I've found that taking breaks on the weekends feels a lot better than
taking breaks in during the weekdays,
because it just feels nice when you know that everyone else in the country and
on the break as well, you know, most
Christmas days, just a regular word. Yeah. Yeah.
And also weekends are a suggestion to stop working. They're not enforced.
Every holidays is a suggestion to some working. Let's be honest to,
uh, to the North of Japan for about three or four days to go see Chris. Um,
and that was really nice. There's so much.
Snow that you make you drink sacking.
Uh, no, he made me drink good sock. Oh yeah.
And also that's an oxymoron for Connor also.
It was the first I did like a proper Japanese Christmas, AKA KFC.
How was it? This is Katie. I, this is just exactly what I thought.
It's just chicken. Like, it's just like a trip to KA.
Although it was kind of weird because Chris had to schedule it like
or book it. Well, KFC, KFC.
We world come to like two, well,
three weeks in advance. Right. And it's also wait, it's not just like, uh,
you not only have to book it,
but you have to book like a day in time to go and pick it off as well.
So it's like,
not only do you have to come in on debt on a certain date to a certain store,
but it's like come between a two to 3:00 PM time bracket and this,
and we went there when there was just like a group of about maybe like five or
six families just lining up to get their Christmas chicken from the kernel and.
Dive in lineup for a case. Yeah.
And I mean, you know,
it was like what we got like a full bucket of like just a bunch of chicken wings.
As you do.
But also at the bottom of the bucket,
there was like this kind of Christmas cake or like Christmas pudding. Right.
I don't know. Cause I don't think anyone had a slice of it,
but it was at the bottom of the thing. And we're like, Oh,
that's a little weird that it's just been sitting underneath this like greasy,
greasy, chicken and no way you'd want to put a cake.
It was the last thing we were expecting at the bottom of the bucket to be fair.
And it was like 5,000 yen for it.
And it could feed maybe about three or four people.
You paid 50 bucks for KFC on Christmas. Oh my God. I mean, I didn't Kristin,
you could've had a nice roast dinner for that.
We ordered all the food just because it was the first time for all of us.
We've never had a Japanese Christmas before, so we're like, you know what, it.
Let's do it. And uh, wouldn't do it again. To be honest, it's just,
it's just KFC. Cause the thing is like, this is,
I think the fourth year that I've been in Asia celebrating Christmas and I got
to say, I, you don't really understand the entire,
the entire like hype behind this. Uh, th th the Christmas spirit,
I thought that was just like, uh, I thought that was just a meme.
It's a marketing point. I didn't,
I didn't understand that until I started spending Christmas outside of,
you know, where, you know, countries that normally celebrate Christmas and,
you know, you can do a lot of things to make it feel Christmas week,
but having spent a few Christmases Christmases in Asia,
I kind of missed that Christmas spirit because there's, there's a few things,
you know, you can put on the Christmas songs and you can do every, you know,
put up the tree, but there's just something missing.
I can't put my finger on it, but it just doesn't feel fully Christmasy.
I think it just has to do with the fact that at least in Japan,
Christmas is not a family thing. It's like a romantic thing.
And also everyone's working. So it's like, like I got a delivery on like,
as we were having our roast dinner and it was like the least,
it was like the immersion breaking Christmas moment where simulation ruined it.
I had an Amazon package and I was like, this is not Christmas.
So the door on your red hat, like I refuse to have this.
The wine in hand, Christmas simulation over.
It was like that Rick and Morty episode where you just trapped in an alternate,
like, like this, this like reality.
Is it like, to me,
Christmas is like going back and reluctantly having to talk to family members
about like, Oh, I do YouTube. You know, this is what I get naked online.
Something like that.
Yes. I make this much per year.
Thank you uncle for asking me another seven times.
You're investing. Right. And a pension, right? Yes. Yes I am. No, I don't know.
Yeah.
I don't know. It felt, it felt odd because I feel like normally.
I didn't, I didn't appreciate Christmas that much. Cause I didn't realize it.
It was a really good way of like in my head, at least,
I don't know if this is because I've been, this is how I taught. It was like,
this is the end of the year. Yeah.
Now go and restart and then build up to all of this.
Cause it was, it was, it's not just Christmas.
It's that period between Christmas, Christmas and new years.
That is just like the blank period where it's just like, what rules,
what are the rules? Nobody knows what's going on. Or the buses running.
I don't know. I shops open. It's anarchy.
And I love that period because it's.
Cool. How, how long can I have leftovers for how many Christmas dinners?
Yeah. That's that, that was like living in England.
That was like one of my favorite parts of the year. It was just,
it was just like you said, like the reset of the, it was like the entire,
the entire society was just kind of goes into cool-down.
Whereas here it's like businesses just like supermarkets and convenience stores
are open literally 24, seven, even on new year's day.
My mum wants, shut off about KFC Christmas. To me, she's fascinated by it.
She's like, I heard they have KFC for Christmas. This is true. And I'm like,
yes, they do mum. I was like, wow, how crazy is that? And I'm like, yeah,
it's kind of weird to be fair. It is bizarre when you think that is weird.
It's like, you know,
just all the things that Japan has no interest in from like the West, right.
When we bring our finest things, I like none of them, none of that,
none of that. And then suddenly the curdle rocks up and he's like, listen,
how about, let me pitch you this
[inaudible] let me take this. Absolutely nothing to do with Christmas food.
And somehow make it Christmas food who did like, Oh my God, like, how did,
how did they pull this off? Like, I'm sure someone knows the history behind it.
But like, to me, even if you explained to me how it was done,
the KFC marketing department did this, explain it to you last time.
But even then it still doesn't make sense to me.
I researched it and it doesn't make sense.
Like it was like the marketing heist of the century. I swear to God.